is here on a bear is here the night of
them want to follow you watch the
hardhome episode there's a lot of very
important conversations that need to
happen in the world right now
and then there's this one Game of
Thrones look enough people have died on
that show that we're clearly down to the
last handful of characters I mean
they're not gonna I'm gonna kill them
all over [ __ ] anyway
clear at this point there's two heroes
worth rooting for the king of the north
or the mother of dragons who's more
deserving to sit on the Iron Throne it's
debatable
[Music]
okay the case Jon Snow you can do all
you want but he is king of the north and
you know what he earned that he came
into this world everyone's told me as a
bastard he thinks beyond just the battle
for the Iron Throne he doesn't even care
about it what has John Donne defended
the wall the wall defends the wall Jon
Snow is just a little speck on top of it
there's a list of all of things Jon Snow
is done he's gone out beyond the wall
face the army of the Dead and not only
has he seen them he's defeated them
peace why is Valyrian steel and killed a
white Walker Jon brought the wildlings
across the wall sets them up with farms
cuz he set them up he does what he has
done some serious [ __ ] he got killed and
then a crazy [ __ ] witch lady brought
him back to life 400 years old it's her
deal she is if you think about the arc
of reborn heroes you have Batman you
have britney Spears's career and should
I say Jesus Christ people always save
John he dies and then a woman saves him
just let a woman have the throne John
can be her little cabana boy he didn't
ask for this people need to follow him
because it's the only thing he just
replaced people when they die people had
to force him to kind of be the king of
the north he didn't even want that he
was like nah I'm not no no he's like
every dude in like a John Hughes movie
where he's just kind of like depressed I
guess I'll be the leader and oh you know
if only if someone else could lead I
feel bad for the north then North feels
bad for itself right now they're like we
made a mistake we should have picked
Santa because Santa's sticks around
Lyanna Mormont did not stand for this
[ __ ] when she's like I stand with Jon
Snow people would rather follow Lyanna
Mormont a ten year old girl cuz she's
super awesome yeah I mean yeah the
amantha [ __ ] yeah
mother of dragons breaker of chains the
unburnt Daenerys is like Katniss and
Moana and every badass woman all rolled
into one she wasn't born and they were
like Khaleesi you're gonna be queen that
never happened Daenerys is sold by her
brother raped by her husband who later
becomes one of the greatest people of
all time r.i.p Khal Drogo Meshach Misha
Ronnie that means my light my stars
every step of the way she has fun I
don't think she does anything no cooler
should like take my saree she nothing
was ever handed to her yes the Dragons
the Dragons the dragon the dragon
different she's their mother she wants
to break the wheel yeah she's got some
bunch of great speeches she's kind of
mixing message and it sounds great
it sounds like this not God well she's
[ __ ] lay in the law down I mean when
her dragons are laying the law no
Daenerys is [ __ ] lame on pretty sure
you meant to say dragons I'm just sayin
she's definitely used like crazy
mechanisms too crazy it's just exactly
just a dragon everyone who lived in
those slave cities they follow her
willingly you think the Dragons had
anything to do with that she said so
many times the dragons are her children
they're basically an extension of her is
she a good mother for having her
children murder people yes how do you
explain her burning those people at the
stake how's that any difference in the
Maggie
he used to burn people too so how about
she freed all people marine okay and
then she enslaved them again she didn't
enslave that don't see great where I'm
taking many vacation days she leads her
new khalasar through the Red Waste so
many people die horses die
she's chapped lips leave her for her
ship she's no better than Littlefinger
they love her so much that they call her
mother
meesa meesa meesa me so tired of this
[ __ ] you Dean
as the immortal Olenna Tyrell said beat
the dragon Daenerys is a dragon Jon Snow
he gets it done he's out there he's seen
some [ __ ] he has conquered death which
is the true enemy and no one else can
say that Daenerys is the only way that
Jon Snow will defeat the White Walkers
and we all [ __ ] know it
and also dragons Jon Snow he pet the
dragon the dragon recognizes him and the
dragon loves him too but conclusion
we're coming to really is we know they
have the hots for each other oh
definitely they just need to like get
together even though they're like third
cousins or onsen menus or whatever does
only brought one other woman to a cave
r.i.p Ygritte
[Music]
there is one point where I thought all
the women were like rising to the top
and they'll [ __ ] died in one moment
they all died they were like they're all
dead and now your odds back is an 80s
dancer
[Music]